patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon what's your wow rabbit
well hennessey's make your move has gotten
off to a great start we had nate hill defeat
i am brandon in the first matchup we
heard from nas we saw the great campaign
that has you in the spotlight maurice but up next
that may be our heavyweight battle of the day
we have gizza and rizza battling it out so
maurice first up we have rizza so you've known
both of these players for a long time right
what can you tell us maybe a fun fact about them
well the thing that's interesting to me is the
intensity level of rizza i mean rizza is the
kind of guy who's he's not here to crack jokes
very thoughtful incredibly intellectual and he
wants to just get it done and let me tell you you
mess with him you're going to get cut so this is
the kind of guy who you like his attitude at the
board he brings out intensity he brings the fire
and we should expect to see him really show
his stuff in this game and he's the producer of
almost all of wu-tang clan's albums and of
course he's been a founding member so he is
well known in the hip-hop industry and he's been
a real inspiration for many of the elite talents
and he's also a competitive chess player though
right he held the hip-hop chess federation belt
he started uh the wuches.com and you know he
just he's a huge lover of the game of chess
i i don't think that anyone should underestimate
his strength absolutely not are you kidding i mean
you're going to see a different game than
the one we just saw between these two
they're going to bring the fire and like you said
he's really heavily into it you know shout out to
adisa banyoko of the hip-hop chess federation
uh adisa is cool cool brother doing his thing
helping the young people out in cali and i really
feel like rizza is is somebody who feels like he
needs to get involved on the ground in order
to uh make a difference for sure and speaking
of helping the young people out jizza who is the
spiritual head if you will of the wu-tang clan he
launched a program titled science genius battles
which motivates young high school students to
learn science through hip-hop to improve science
education in new york city of course he had the
legendary grand master's album which is should
be a chess anthem for every single player and
absolutely you know a nod to the highest level
achievement in chess each song in the album had
a theme of chess play so clearly a chess lover and
he looks like a thinker just based on that image
that we have in front of us a thinker a scientist
a philosopher is absolutely all of that put
together uh he brings the intelligence he brings
the acumen and he brings the passion for change
as well as you see is his contributions to the
worlds and i got to give it up for wuten that
they have used their credibility uh their
fame their notoriety to make a difference
and it's a beautiful thing to have them on doing
this and the fact that they want to help such a
beautiful cause as well no accident whatsoever and
i'm really happy and proud to see these brothers
continue to represent in the highest way
and the time has come it has indeed and
well giza gets the white pieces and it
looks like rizza he is 2005 rated so wow
maurice you sure you want to take that handicap
against uh somebody like rizza i'm sure i don't
but wow i mean look at that you already got the
queen's gambit in effect on the board uh c4 e6 i
mean these guys are not horsing around they know
how to play and he knows to just grab that pawn
and c4 you're not gonna keep it anyway so playing
very solidly we'll see now a total difference
already knight f3 you see this already between
the first game and this one you see centralization
peace development so far very natural i mean
this could be a game between me and you james
yeah really really i mean absolutely we're gonna
have to see what happens here and actually get
that game actually to happen too i mean look at
this you know this pawn on c4 has been hanging for
a while but this is how strong they are they know
you don't just take something that may look free
it's dangling in front of you but that would give
white better control over the center by releasing
this e2 pawn up to e4 so that's why the tension
has been kept they often say that strong players
know when to keep the tension and both these
players coming out really with some great strength
i'm really i'm really waiting for the mistake
and a3 that one is a slight unnecessary slightly
unnecessary move at this point so one i was a
little off move because the bishop is already
on e7 so it didn't intend to go to b4 so i would
have anticipated knight c3 so at least we've seen
slight off move at the moment not a big deal but
look at this c6 semi semi slop territory guys
hit him with the semi inverted v formation right
here this when you look at this you say i don't
know who's playing is this magnus and levon or
is this razer gizza this is what we want to know
well we we can hear their thoughts
right now we'll take a listen in and
i really hope that they're trash
talking each other i want to hear that
okay i must have missed that last
move and i realized you moved already
okay let me squeak up in that case
i just wasted a minute thinking it was your move
must have been the beat yeah it
must have been in a b i try my head
okay
let's do something different here
and in a continuing trend they were completely
silent when we tuned and they just know
and they have that sense but they did get
a little bit uh chattier as time went on
and that was funny to hear hey i didn't even
realize it was my move that happens to all of us
wasted a minute wasting a minute bro he
still has time he still has time on the
clock uh to handle it but as you can tell this
maneuver knight a6 knight c7 we would say is
less traditional uh in chess but unorthodox to
be sure the knight on c7 really would prefer to
be on d7 it could have gone there in one move and
we see not wasting any time trading after age six
already we see a major difference
have we seen any blunders yet
no no we have we've seen any moves that didn't
at least give a nod to the center of the board
no we're seeing all that we're not seeing perfect
play we're not seeing grand master chess even
master level but we are seeing good moves get
played and these guys are not just hanging pieces
i mean i'm this is going to be a very interesting
match whoever wins this is going to be a very
interesting opponent for nate to be sure
given his level of play look at castling early
white's pieces are just perfect i mean the knight
i may not have put on b3 but guys we're seeing the
game who's there's intentionality in every single
move and that's what's every move both sides king
safe uh the only misplaced piece really i mean i
give white the nod here because of the bishop on
c8 and the knight on c7 but i wouldn't make
i wouldn't bet any money on who's gonna win
this game like zero i have no idea 95 do you
see this centralizing the 90s knight on e5
and you can't play f6 because the knight g6 try
it play f6 if you like yeah i mean he knows he
needs to get rid of that knight though so he
plays bishop f6 understanding i shouldn't push
the pawn let me get the bishop here all right
now i'm curious to see the next move this is
going to say a lot this very next is going to say
a lot because something like 93 blunders heavily
if you drop the knight back to d3 f4 looks like an
automatic move if you're going to play knight e5
if you play if he plays f4 right now then
you know i'm just going to start practicing
the prep buttons you play a move like f4 it
means you understand you can spot that go
we'll see what the next move is uh you know this
this is this is good stuff and f4 can be a tough
move to play if you're not super familiar with
these kind of stone wall pawn strikes with pawns
on d4 and f4 solidifying the center he could be
thinking a little bit i was about to say he could
be thinking in a reactionary manner by removing
the knight from attack but it still has a clear
purpose so even though that's maybe not a move
that we'd see the magnus carlsons of the world
play i think it's a very good move i actually like
to move along definitely pressuring that bishop on
f6 and again one trade has occurred in this entire
game a bishop for a night no pawns have been
traded off there's no premature moves being played
now b6 played willingly parting with the bishop on
f6 so that he can get his bishop into the game
we're seeing solid pawn formation no blunders
nothing this is a game we've got to pay attention
now to the clock actually as a factor in the
game as well we certainly do i think this one's
going the distance just based on the locked up
structure that we have here c5 trying to break
it open and then put a rook on c1 behind the pawn
and that's the good thing about knights they're
better closed positions if there's open space
the bishops thrive but i think that giza played
a very good move there with c5 sorry answers
certainly an interesting move and you just you see
the thoughtfulness as well i mean people are are
looking and saying aren't these guys rappers and
they're supposed to have a certain kind of vibe
braggadocio and the like and you're seeing
the rapper scientists like i said the rapper
philosopher the thinker at work the mind you
could just see deep into the game they're not even
interested in trash talking each other i think in
part because they're such long time friends i mean
it's i can imagine it's very hard to start this in
your boy you know like this is my boy i wait for
the next match when i'm playing somebody i don't
really know and who i heard talk trash on me as
well because nate did call them out so wait until
they wait until they play you maurice the trash
i'm definitely trash talking you can oh man
i'm just gonna have to egg them on because
i just want to hear them freestyle you know
i really want to hear them show their skills
because they're just such great wordsmiths they
have such wonderful ideas you know expressiveness
so i really want to have that come out not not
just to try to distract them but here we see
bishop e7 on the board and again very solid game
guys positional solid if i had white i'd feel
comfortable but i wouldn't say i was winning or
even much better right you just have more space
but why don't we hear their thoughts because i
i want them to talk to each other i don't know
if they are but let's take a listen in very
quickly don't look like they're talking man
we've been we've had bad luck next
time we switch let's make it short
unless they start says they start talking
but let's hear what they have to say
okay nice and serious
now you're talking serious business with me
and i don't like it
yeah that's the quality
oh
well as both players let their moves do the
talking we have to shout out and thank some of
our huge contributors here we had donations from
chesapeake and michelle thank you so much and just
a reminder that uh you can click on the donate
button on chess.com the about page hennessey's
pledge to match all contributions to the chess.com
twitch channel with the charity donation up to 250
000 so thank you so much to those who have
already donated and who will continue to but
maurice james we have a very intense chess game
underway where rizza put his pawn on f5 and
you know he tried to close down that
bishop and queen that were on the diagonal
also guarding the e4 square making that a very
difficult break and by the way did you see his
move queen e8 did you guys peak that i saw it
96 threat and also the threat to the c6 pawn so
he ain't big fella right just one move it man and
the queen was on d8 there was a threat if you just
go back one one move as well it was a threat to
either play knight g6 and potentially take your
dark square bishop with knight g6 and also there
was a threat to take on b6 and pick off the pawn
on c6 because the knight would have been attacking
with the queen attack uncovered that's a double
threat and the mere fact that he played queen
e8 come on guys that is a player right that is
somebody who sees moves and he saw the move right
there and then he said it's time for your knight
to leave and here comes my queen into that side
and okay his bishop really would like to get away
from b7 and be on e4 if you could just jump that
piece all the way to e4 then you'll be able to
sweet square so he's still not really threatening
anything on that side but i'm still wondering like
what's gonna happen in this game i mean these guys
are not blundering they're playing solid chess
they're getting it done in this game and again
i'm going to say a lot is going to hinge on the
clock management how to handle themselves when we
get to just a down to a minute or two and how they
handle that kind of time pressure because right
now they're playing chess rizza definitely had
a great initiative swing here especially after
queenie ate the queen g6 the knight was on e5 and
then moved to f3 so he missed that f4 move which
could have probably granted him a little bit more
initiative maybe followed by even g4 and start a
king side attack due to the locked up bishop on
b7 but the problem is that he moved it back to f3
moving the knight multiple times as kappa blanket
says you should refrain from doing so is now uh
under some pressure i would think here rizza could
could swing this yeah it's interesting because i
do believe that sometimes they're playing a little
bit reactionary but they still have purpose
in their moves and well maurice knight to b5
i can capture that thing and try to open up the
c file push my pawn to c6 what do you think rizza
has spotted here and he has done so he did capture
on b5 but cece might be a mistake as a rook c8
and now that was i was going to say that now the
question becomes do you really want to do that
move because yes maybe you have this past pawn
but you got you're going to have the business
of having to hold on to this pawn although
there is some kind of sacrifice of the queen on
on b7 by capturing on b7 that's hyper risky i'm
trying to calculate it i don't think it works
in fact sacrificing here because black can
probably just bring the queen back to f7 and
then the b pawn is going to drop so something to
calculate but doesn't work out for black but look
at the variations we're analyzing you feel me i
mean we're actually looking at lines like that
variations right variations and he saw it
he didn't play c6 he played queen d3 hitting
the b pawn and now a capture on c5 c5 knight c5
hitting the ball on on b7 the e pawn on e6 the b
pawn on b5 yeah in the house follows the house
stuff this is this is and how do you guard all
of it there's no way to guard all of that oh my
goodness this is now a tangible advantage and
he could just grab it looks like the pawn on b5
and it's again it's gonna be about the clock they
each at three minutes and change three minutes 24
seconds three minutes 22 seconds this is now going
to be a matter of trying to manage the clock and
he did b4 he played b4 positions he didn't grab
that right away and he allowed a6 now he still has
an overwhelming advantage these knights will spank
these bishops any day especially that bishop
on c8 is going oh my goodness thanks for that
dominant knight on c5 so he can easily double
on the c line this is a game robert i would see
you in a tournament playing against some master
level player and just take give them some lessons
and our point is that black can't really move
very easily every single move has a consequence
you want to free this bishop on ca but oh gosh
i was about to say e5 runs into pawn takes pawn
queen with a check and the rook falls in the
club i don't know what to do here i don't know
what to say i'm about to jump out to see but
i got to sit down so the moment he missed it
he missed it missed the tactical opportunity to
win at least a bishop at least in that position
and instead because here after this move you
pointed out takes and takes back on e5 queen
takes would be check bishop e6 might be the
only way to save your rook i would imagine but
that's going to lose at least another piece
so this was devastating this would have been
crushing and he missed it that missed the tactic
and so that's we've seen at least as a weakness on
his part and now suddenly black is the one who's
got some moves going maybe play f4 and go for it
with the initiative on the king's side missed the
break he played h5 this this game is up in the
air guys and two minutes each one of them has on
the clock and i know i can tell that they played
each other many times before just by the way that
jesus reacting i'm sure that rizzo has had some
cool sacrifices and winning tactics against jesus
and that's why he's saying wait i don't want to be
attacked anyway i'm going to just play a solid
approach but right now it is feeling like it's
black's game for the taking for rizza because as
you said maurice f4 comes in that bishop slides
into h3 that king on g1 is awfully lonely over
here yeah big opportunity and also the bishop
on f6 can probably slide back to e7 and go to d6
and have a beautiful diagonal there for the attack
did he actually play the move he played bishop
e7 yeah oh my gosh see i i was i was thinking
like that's just high level maybe he might not
spot a retreating move to reposition yourself
look that's a serious move and now black has got
f4 on tap the bishops that i was just deriding
they're about to ride this position to the sunset
i mean this is beautiful black is starting to show
some stuff white has to deal with the initiative
that's coming at him f3 trying to maybe hold
up this attack not a bad idea actually because
if he gets an f4 he can shut the position down
and and black himself may not necessarily want to
play a four at this moment yeah clear he doesn't
want to sit and wait for rizzo to come attack him
he's saying i'm not going down without a fight so
oh that queen's f3 watch out the d5 pawn we've
seen that riz has overlooked that square once
in this game i don't think he's going to miss it
again let's see here but it's a real threat it's a
real real threat and this time hard to defend he's
already missed it oh my goodness i don't know will
he see queen takes d5 check a second time a second
opportunity that would be a devastating blow by
the way jesus is down to 146 [ __ ] it did see he
takes d5 why did it check wow what's on the board
hanging as well the king is under attack this
one is all day courageous all day right now today
you know but it is getting into time trouble
so if i'm brazil i'm like yeah just go
just go go f4 now you've got to make moves
now you've got to be quick now you've got
to rely on instinct and will if he's being
a bit ponderous right now thinking about it
okay challenge the queen okay maybe not it's not
it's not the best idea because queen g3 and then
bishop d6 is going to give counterplay to black
so i didn't like weakening those dark squares
does he see the rook is hanging guys this is the
oh my god right does he see it i'm telling you
there's something about this game that tells
me he has lost and been checkmated by rizza
a number of times because that rook was hanging
he finally stole upon but i'm with you i'm with
you maurice that these dark squares scare me so
after queen g3 i don't think he's gonna go bring
his queen to the corner even though it's a full
rook okay we'll come back to the gym okay queen
back to g6 now let me tell you something that's a
rook is a rook is a rook that's a rook it's a rip
i mean f4 is still going to give some counter
play for black that's going to be dangerous
and you're still going to have to calculate
that but i'd like i like taking the rook and ff4
queen evil he didn't take the rook he didn't
take the rook he gave black another chance
and now black can definitely bring
the bishop out to e6 save the rook
and the game continues but guess what 129 against
103 the clock is starting to be a huge factor
somebody might lose on time i told you guys
this from the beginning right right when you see
logical moves like this they're so thoughtful that
they might lose on the clock they might they don't
know how to get this might get wild yeah this is
only down to 46 seconds i think one player will
lose on time and not even realize it that might
be where we're going with this good move though
bring that rook over that's his
plan so nice d3 look at the reroute
oh nice nice and instantly and now they're
starting to speed up now i think they're
feeling oh bishop h4 bishop h4 h4 looks cool
my goodness that's out easy have a nice day
nice move the queen cannot counter because
mate that's going to cost gizza a few seconds
to feel this position look at that counter play
razor just through adam hitting bishop h4 wow
or d2 only moves okay so he drops the queen
back all right drop back still ahead on the
clock that's the good news for jizzy even
though he's dropping in exchange he already
was up a pawn and his knights are about
to dominate the dark squares whoa whoa
no no no this man was too exuberant sacrifices
with 28 seconds and now look at the speed they're
playing at but white has two gorgeous knights
no way in the world this is winning for white
but will he do it in time as they are starting
to play blitz use the dark squares and let's
listen and hear their thoughts as we get down
the stretch here hopefully uh the players can
provide some more entertainment
than they already are over the board
and that pawn is going really far so
they're both silent oh it's in my phone
dominant night move that's going to leave a
mark rook cakes give me your rook with check
and just as owning this game right now we can
just protect this knight or move it and this
this is all white right up two nights with
just a little bit of time left on the clock
9.3 seconds i mean when they
started to play blitz it turned into
like a real slugfest they knew what exactly what
they were doing on the blitz side as well they
can play fast when they need to man jesus made he
has missed some great moves that win him the game
but he hasn't made any tremendous
blunders it felt like and he is just
gobbling up pawns that king on h6 should be
checked in just a few moves yeah he could
have won a rook it looks like with rook g6 check
would have been game over but now rook h5 is made
he has the chance again will he see it a
second time around he's got 40 seconds left
on his clock and he has rook that's a mate oh
and he left roman away he better hope like flag
is there that doesn't cost him later yeah that was
a big miss here uh i think that he's still oh rick
takes a four that was desperate that's desperation
this is johnny ball game now he can just start
queening pawns this is over he maybe he's hoping
for a stalemate all right well i think they're
talking so let's listen in as their the game is
about to conclude and they're jesus you're talking
been a draw game the king has no legal moves and
he didn't move oh my goodness i don't think that
do you think jesus would have queen there we have
to ask them when we get them on later correct we
gotta x unreal right at the moment when the trap
was at its finest point and he didn't move he
ended up losing on time when he had only one move
on the board and weaning would have stalemated
with no moves for the king it cannot walk into
check despite having all that extra material the
game would have been a draw and unfortunately for
riza he didn't get the chance fortunately for us
because i don't know what happens in the case of
a draw what do we do flip a coin like what would
you have done to the side of the champion but i
don't even know the answer that but i do think
that gizza was the worthy winner of that game oh
absolutely he took it to rizzo he was too cautious
we'll have to ask him you know about their
playing history between the two of them but it
felt like he had a clear plan he had a purpose for
almost all of his moves let me tell you something
if you have to pick right now between nate and
gizza that's gonna be a game that's gonna be
a game from what i just saw i think giza
could give him time odds and still win wow
and still win you're even trash talking nate
right now you know he's a buddy but if you just
look at what just happened here look at the
rating next to rizz's name 2005 that doesn't
happen by accident that is a serious player and
gizza from the start of the game to the finish
he looked like the guy who was in charge had
more time too and more time very not his tactics
we would say not as sharp as they should be but
in terms of his strategic intent the ability
to harmonize forces get his pieces into the game
king safety advancing pawns and when the technical
phase came by the way the finish line the mop
up operation and then time to promote a pawn i
mean pure intent yeah he may not be a grandmaster
level player but he played with grandmaster intent
all the way throughout he was very much focused on
what he wanted to get done and he did it kudos to
him definitely the deserved winner and when you're
dropping albums by the name of uh grandmasters
i think you gotta play like one every now and then
and he he polished him off that was a pretty clean
game we should highlight that one move bishop
h4 by rizzo which was excellent and routed his
pieces that was a really nice stuff so let me uh
bring that position up again absolutely sterling
move i think i mean you see a move like that drop
on the board and that's the thing about the level
of players right guys they fight they might not
play the most accurate moves and then they play
a move like this you go whoa who's playing black
like right his level hustle did he his husband
the problem is inconsistency because he played
bishop h4 and after queen f1 instead of pocketing
the exchange which by the way blacks black is
not winning white still has compensation those
knights are boss pieces but instead of pocketing
exchange he immediately blundered bishop takes g2
and his opponent was not frazzled he took on
g2 and that cost him both bishops against the
very stable knights and that turned into a big
problem in this end game is why white ended up
winning the game and that's a sign of a very good
player is when you were blunders aren't that bad
for you like jesus blunder was still a pretty good
looking position he would have lost a rook for a
bishop and a pawn and had those knights that were
still going to dominate so that is the sign of an
excellent player and rizza 2 had some very good
moments it just felt like he was on his back foot
out of the opening yeah these are players that
need some more some more depth in their game it's
definitely some tactical puzzles that they should
be solving on a regular basis to get to get their
eyes sharper but in terms of basic explanations if
they said to james uh james could you give us some
lessons james couldn't be talking about well you
know you should be developing your pieces rook is
worth five and the bishop is word three they'll
be like yo uh-uh bring the real knowledge please
bring the candy knowledge because we need the real
deal because they can play that's right yeah it
was a very great game today what we saw here in
the in the end is where it really became uh like
i like to say for even magnus has time trouble
and when time trouble does happen you are prone
to make mistakes here and i think time got to him
he saw him getting low jesus is still up on time
and then he started to make mistakes there and
the rest is history it happens to the best of us
it certainly does well we are going to bring
both of these players on for a discussion and
we of course want to hear their thoughts and
we're just going to take a break now but when
we return we will have rizza and jizza joining
us for some fun and some analysis be right back
to defeat your opponent you must become
your opponent what's your wow rabbit
we are back and jizz and rizza in the building yo
fellas that was exciting man that was fun that was
an interesting game uh it was it was very solid
at the start i know you guys played each other so
many times over so many years tell me first i'll
start with you jizza what did it feel like now
playing your man literally in front of a big
audience online like i said it felt like we
were in the world series of chess what it felt
like was because of knowing that there's an
audience watching us so it's kind of intimidating
in that sense but we're used to playing each other
and i'm questioning about that rizza
playing each other being so familiar with each
other's styles did you feel that impacted the game
um yeah it kind of impacted the game definitely in
the beginning phase you know when just does that
that queen gambit which is my i hate that game um
and normally when he when he does that uh opening
i'm always facing some type of difficulties but
playing him so many times i felt prepared for it
but i see that uh his kung fu was better than
mines today now i feel you the game was very
solid from the beginning we we go through the
moves and we were just rapping about it and
saying all these moves look like grandmaster moves
we can't even tell the difference between you guys
and top level players mostly in the opening your
knight a6 putting the knight on the side and
swinging it to the middle that was unorthodox to
be sure but nothing to say it was really bad but
is that how your games usually go very solid like
this giza you you handle this so deliberately like
you you didn't want to go for the attack right
away you just seem to be building up the space
slowly but surely well you know um playing with
rizzo he's a very patient player and usually i
i'm i'm quick to make moves before really thinking
it out sometimes especially when we're playing on
a clock we're playing some type of blitz game and
and i haven't played the queen's gamut with him
in a long time so this is the first time in a
while i said you know because he usually have an
answer for it um the last few times i i tried it
with him but i just went for it this time you know
and rizza you you had this position as we start
building forward we just go a little bit ahead
it was very solid everybody castled and and uh you
chased the knight out of the position as well at
what point did you feel as we move fast forward
that maybe you were having some difficulties in
the position because his pieces were starting to
look lively i think i felt the most difficulty
when uh when i kind of blundered and opened up
the check for the attack on the rook um i can't
see the screen right now what you guys are looking
at but that attack on the rook um was the first
like punching the rib for me but then i saw my
position and i saw my bishops also had strength to
potentially get a mate out of them and so i wasn't
really devastated by it but what got once once he
started you know you know joseph was very patient
he was squeezing he was kind of squeezing me there
um but i did uh i felt that if he came if he
removed this queen and went up that foul to take
the rook i had a couple of answers for that right
you got some counter play trying to attack him now
i'm curious gizza why didn't you gobble on that
rook i mean the rook was sitting right there
it takes a lot i mean that was just something i
obviously overlooked you talking about the rook
that was at a8 yes exactly yeah i obviously over
over overlooked that or i would have captured it
i didn't i didn't realize it until i made the next
move went because i pushed the pawn up attacking
the queen right right then then when once he moved
retreated with the queen i made a i made the next
move and then after making that move i realized
that the rook was already open to be captured so
it was something that i didn't even see by the
way are you looking at a chessboard right now
i'm looking at the one that's on the screen
wherever you are okay because i was wondering if
you were actually doing all this from the memory
but i can i can see yeah i can see the setup
okay i'll see you right here as well all right so
that's after the queen retreated after attacking
exactly h3 right yeah you attacked him with h3
right and then i just noticed after i moved i
forgot the move i made after that did i move the
you move your queen back and then he saved his
rook i believe a rook right i moved the queen
back and then he saved then he saved the rook
and then after i moved again he did bishop to b7
yeah because that was the winning move right there
you played yeah now explain to me after queen f2
you played this spectacular shot bishop h4 we were
super excited about it when the queen dropped
back you didn't take the rook you decided to
play bishop takes g2 why did you do that
well my clock so in the beginning of the
game i think i made a you know i came
in dancing right had my beat machine
and so i lost maybe about 30 40 seconds
not even knowing that he made a move right
right and they caught up with me at the end so
when i when i looked at my clock i was like wow
i'm down to 36 seconds which is 36 chambers but
then at 36 seconds uh i basically went into that
panic mode of of of the about when we play each
other on the clock we got a slogan we use called
blowing up like like the bomb is about to blow
up and so i felt the pressure of the bomb about
to blow up and so instead of of course taking
the world first he catches back and then maybe
sacrificing uh queens and all that and putting
myself in a better position if i would have had
another minute i would have did it i would have
made that decision but based on the pressure i
was like maybe i could get him to spin some of
his clocks and maybe it'll become a time game
and he didn't fall for it at all i love the way
you guys describe chess i love the the lingo
you use uh of course at the end it was great
technique on the part of gizza and he ended up
getting this done so congratulations great game we
really were entertained by it i'm gonna bring in
my boys robert gm robert hess and masterman james
canty so they can come on in and join the party
we had a lot of fun but i know they asked some
questions for you for sure first of all that was
an awesome game you two clearly are quite good and
i could tell you've had many battles between you
my first question i guess for you uh gizza is
when and where did you learn to play chess well
i've learned to play chess many
many years ago i was taught
by a cousin of mine when i was really really
young but uh i was only taught uh the names of
the pieces and their movements so that's the first
time i learned how to play chess and then i didn't
begin to play to many many years later maybe
91 92 when i started playing with master killer
i was reintroduced to the game so that's when
i officially started playing chess although i
knew how to move the pieces and the names of the
pieces i officially started playing around 92 with
master killer and what about you rizza well i had
the privilege of uh you know growing up in a hood
and had a young lady who lived upstairs for me
i was about 11 years old and she taught me how
to play chess and took my virginity and so i
had the process of you know practicing chess
and practicing man at the same time and i
love the game ever since you can see why
good memories yeah all right there's a question
for you rizza you once said hip-hop is a ba is
a is a battle game and chess is a battle so in
your eyes what are the parallels between the two
and how has chess influence your music well you
know chess definitely is a battle it's a war
and you know hip-hop started with the foundation
of dj battles break dancing battles best graffiti
tags and of course mc battles so that warrior
spirit exists in chess and exists in martial
arts and it exists in hip-hop and you know
chess is affecting my life in the sense of
regardless of of whether players are good
or not chess makes you think analytically
you have to look ahead and most times we
find ourselves in trouble is because we
didn't think twice or three times about the
problem before we face it very good thank you
and uh jizz i got a question for you uh next
month marks the 25th anniversary of liquid swords
which is i mean honestly considered by many to
be a masterpiece uh chess is woven throughout the
lyrics so what's it about the game that inspires
your creativity and drive to achieve greatness
um many different things um you know to reflect
back on what rizzo was saying chess is a game
of uh it's a battle um you can re uh resembles
war you have many different pieces on the board
that does different movements you know and hip hop
when we started rhyming many years ago we used to
walk across all through the borough battling mc's
challenging these style and sharpening our swords
against one another um it's it's
a strategic game it's tactical
planning moves ahead just as in rhyming you know
you plan ahead if you're about to battle someone
you you you're watching what they do and then
you're studying their style and their structure
and then you're writing for that and preparing for
the game or the battle itself so they kind of uh
parallel each other in such a sense for sure
um yeah i mean it makes a lot of sense rizza
how about you i mean how have the skills you've
developed from chess helped you push the limits
of your potential well i'm you know even in the
business i try to think ahead and try to calculate
and then one thing about chess i think
that really resonates with me is that
you know you're you're you know you're governing
multiple pieces so you know as a movie director or
producer you're dealing with different musicians
different personalities and you're out for one
goal and that goal means you kind of got to have
this octopus brain in all reality and chess to me
trains that for me it trains it trains this multi
i call it multivision it trains the multivision
potential inside of me as a creator and so whether
you know i've seen myself be on movie sets and
having a tough day and at lunch time i may
go play a game of chess at lunch you know i
mean i have one of my buddies reverend william
burke he'll be on the set and he'll be waiting
in the trailer for for lunch and i'll come in
lunch and i'll play and i'll think and it'll
exercise those muscles and i go back out and i
try to face the problem that's in front of me
beautifully said absolutely beautifully said chest
as relaxation and stimulation but i'm gonna say
jizza you've won that game but there was
a little bit of trash talking from your
next opponent nate hill he we asked him
what he was looking forward to projects
and the like he said i'm just looking forward
to who i'mma beat next when risen just a play
what are your thoughts about him trash
talking you guys right out the gate
he's not even played you yet it's all good
sometimes it's part of the game you know and
there's a lot of trash talking in mostly all
competitions even in sports you know boxers
trash talk each other before they jump in the
ring and sometimes the trash talker get trashed
hey just i should have bit your
ear that fight right there though
yeah i was like man i call it it was in the
room sometimes we'd be playing and you know
you know we we're family so we'll be playing
and it might get so tough you might just
turn the pieces over like yo forget it and
just walk away with the with the uh with the
defeat but i will you know as i pass the mic
back to you guys i definitely want to say this
this has uh been a unique experience for me um you
know national chess day is something that uh i'm
happy to be a part of in our reality and happy to
be invited here on this platform and and you know
the chess community um i think the chess community
sometimes is not all-inclusive you know what i
mean and this feels like a very inclusive advance
i want to thank you guys for inviting us to it
no problem no problem uh over to you how many
members of wu-tang clan play chess and are
there any particular tense chess battle stories
um myself rizza master killer method man plays
uh he knows how to play but he doesn't really
play a lot i mean i haven't seen him on the board
in years but he knows how to play the game
the rebel lioness inspector deck plays
i said master killer right mathematics oh
a lot of mathematics plays our dj and um
that's that's pretty much it i've never seen
you guard playing rayquan or ghost face killer
yeah but we've had many many games uh between
myself rizza and master killer and a lot of
times there's there's some you know with me and
master killer there's a lot of trash talking
going back and forth playing so long for so many
years i i think i played the most games with him
than anybody so there's always this competitive
thing with us when it when it comes to chess yeah
who has the better score um
we we go back and forth we go
like when i play master killer we usually
play uh 12 games we do it like a boxing um
fight like a 12 rounds of boxing yeah and then
sometimes it can be really bad it could be nine
to three in my favor and sometimes it could
be nine three in his favor sometimes wow
six sometimes just eight four it
just goes it goes back and forth
and wow you guys have a really good team you guys
could feel the team for a serious chess tournament
yeah really though you got a squad i want
to see wutan versus uh the streamers like
that whole match bring bring four of them versus
for the streamers and see what's on wu-tang yep
risk it all uh well guys gotta have one more
question for you for the time being before we
just you got another game to play uh but uh you
both are cultural icons and hip-hop legends you
push the limits in your mind to build long-lasting
legacies what has been your greatest life lesson
usually you go first greatest life lesson oh man
there's been there's been several of those um
damn what has been my greatest life lesson that's
one of those hard questions to answer man because
you get old enough man you have a lot of lessons
in life i would say to learn all you can learn
yeah i'm not gonna ask it out you know i
answered that question with the blessing of uh
you know for those who don't know us you know
we we um deal with knowledge of ourselves right
and the enlightener the person who told me to seek
knowledge of myself is actually jizza you know i
mean um so he gave me a spark you know back at
the age of 11 and told me to seek knowledge of
myself and study and i never stopped studying
from that day you know never stop studying and
it's always thank him as being uh the the spark
that lit my candle because once my candy was lit
i was able to light so many others so you know
to the just the jizzer in the building by here